yeah I wanted to ask what was like the
fan but Phantom you pissed off the most
and uh we can we can share I guess so I
would say actually probably Dragon Ball
Z really but I just never I've never
made like a negative video about Dragon
Ball Z those guys are just mad they're
angry about a lot of things
honestly probably the bleach fandom
which I mean fair I mean they're still
making Reddit posts in 2022 about why
they're still mad but they're all trying
to collectively figure it out yeah why
are we still mad
I learned earlier they almost started
doing the like the whole Sebastian thing
I I noticed that like people assumed
because I was making videos on it that I
understood a lot about the show but I
didn't and I realized very quickly that
people care about the show way more than
I ever could and I am never ever gonna
attempt to get to their level I'm just
gonna be the hehe funny videos right
that don't even try to touch it or the
themes because they'll do I remember
people can't be like oh this character
wouldn't say this I'm like I don't care
but she this is the thing where like I
feel like when I started making videos
and definitely like when when like you
start making videos like you could make
a video about you you Haka show and it
would be the video on you you Haka show
yeah yeah now you have channels that are
entirely about one piece channels that
are entirely about bleach Dragon Ball Z
and like it's these guys whole lives
like reading this manga and making
content out of it yeah like fair play to
them like that's that's it it's an
interesting way and there's a lot of
good videos that come from that but I
think then the problem is
when you try and make a video about it
then there is infinitely more knowledge
about it and people who might like know
the series more in depth and have more
understanding yeah but then the problem
that it comes into then is like a lot of
like I guess more casual people are
looking for videos where it's kind of
it's entertaining yeah you know exactly
and it comes into this thing where it's
like you have an audience that wants a
really deep understanding and then you
want a bigger audience that just want to
be entertained yeah and I think the
disparity between those two can lead to
I would say like a bit of bitterness
with creators and like I I get it to a
degree but it's a tricky one yeah I mean
one of my most interesting things are
like I've noticed with like some of my
own content so I found him that I've
pissed off uh is the Fate fandom or I
would say the the only guy talks about
it
uh and it was very interesting because
like I made like a skit just like
basically based around my experiences
whenever I would have a conversation
about the Fate rabbit hole and just like
how how like just one sentence could
just start an entire war in terms like
watch order and stuff like that and when
I released that video it was like
received very very positively everyone
[__] loved it
and then it really started getting
spread around and it started getting
spread around outside just the fake
Community uh and that's when I started
to see people not exactly mad about the
video but mad about people's perception
because of that video that is the exact
same thing it was with me like like I
even went on some calls with some some
bleach guys and it always ended up
ultimately yeah yeah I was like okay
let's hear him out and it always ended
at like well I'm not mad at you I'm just
mad at the people who agree with you and
I was like oh okay
oh my God yeah because it's it's so
interesting now because yeah like you
said back then because the anime
Community was much smaller much more as
I would say like inclusive not no not in
conclusive is the wrong word but much
more manageable in terms of like what
fans or what now because there are so
many different factions so many
different fandoms a lot of fans get very
protective about this one IP you know
especially at like anime fan doesn't
worry is like too broad an umbrella now
that just didn't exist before you know I
feel like when you're an anime fan
before that kind of encapsulated so much
of the community and now there are just
people who just solely watch One Piece
for example or solely Watch Attack on
Titan or the shonens I have a fun
question
if you were to do the fall of another
anime today which one would you do the
fall of another anime so like an anime
that fell off the real answer is
probably I would not do that
um
the one that you felt like you kind of
you know fell out of do you think any
anime has fallen off
no I do not
know I think anime is great
would you like to hear top 10 facts
about One Piece
you're like man this sucked for years
they hate me I'm like do it again
um honestly like genuinely like I can
tell you ones that like I I fell off one
piece but that's not because I think one
piece got worse it's because I got real
busy I didn't have time to I'm like I'm
gonna catch up with it someday and I I
bet it's silly
yeah I mean I kind of I never fall out
of one piece I just it just comes in
like waves I there's a wave where I
greet 100 chapters and then I don't read
it for two years and I'm like I I forget
I'm a one-piece fan sometimes yeah and I
read it again I'm like oh yeah I'm
definitely totally yeah do you guys feel
like you're at the point where like even
very milktose opinions get like these
crazy reactions like someone will ask me
like what do you think Rick Demon's
there and I'm like oh yeah it's all
right and I'll be like
Joey about his tradition opinion I think
we did initially because obviously it
was it was all new but I think now
people are so used to us just saying
dumb [__] that his writers off right oh
God Joey
the the new the title for the new season
of Attack on Titan I quite retweeted and
all I said was this title is really
stupid God the comments were just like
how [__] dare you I can't believe you
would say that how dare you ruin the
sanctity of the final season part three
part two you don't even watch anime
anymore you have no opinion on this and
I'm just like guys I just I just thought
it was dumb but yeah like that's why if
I don't really like something I try not
to like say my like opinion even if I
just say it's all right like even it's
all right it's it's even saying like
it's all right it's like fandoms will
jump on you for just saying you don't
think it's really really good or really
really great right Joey right yeah
totally yeah I think uh one one Infamous
trash basically was when Joey said was
like all right or did you use the word
mid I can't remember
okay that was that was the issue
I'm at this point now where it's like
you know I obviously try to avoid you
know giving any like I guess
controversial opinions on like certain
shows but at the same time it's really
funny to piss off anime fans yeah that's
the problem is that I think people like
they hate that yeah I know but
mid is such a lazy criticism I agree I
don't like the turn mid just because I
feel like it is a coward term
I agree you say it [__] or say it's
awesome [__] so you have to actually
like explain what you don't want to do
yeah yeah I'm happy to explain why I
don't like a show I just it might be
[__] stupid is the problem and people
recognize that of me and I'm guilty of
that but I think sometimes like
especially when people are watching you
a lot and people really think they
relate to you they really want to
connect with you on whatever they can
yeah and then it's really disappointing
when they can't like I remember it was
basically a rite of passage in my
Discord for a couple of years for
someone new to come in and be like can't
wait for the boy you should watch hero
Academia video and I just be like I
don't like that show and they're like
and then like the other Discord members
would be like yeah yeah we all we all
thought he was gonna make it
always would because like I know the
feeling where it's just like you just
want to make content on stuff you like
and you shouldn't you know healthily you
shouldn't put your opinions on someone
else's opinion you should kind of like
helpfully form your own but there is a
certain sense of satisfaction you get
when you watch a Creator you respect say
that they like a thing that you like
like when when I saw like Charlie
finally get into one piece I was like we
did it boys we did it we did it we
prevailed uh I knew I shouldn't like
have said have felt that much sense of
Pride but I kind of did yeah yeah it's
like getting your mate into a you know a
show or series you really really like
like have you ever showed a mate like a
or like a first episode of something and
you're just like intently watching them
I don't do that anymore you don't do
that anymore I can't do it it's too it's
too much it's like when you play like
music to someone and it's like the most
it's the longest four minutes of your
life because you're like yeah it's good
right and suddenly it starts to sound
worse it's really good yeah yeah and
suddenly it all starts to sound a little
more uncomfortable and you're like it
just doesn't sound like this when I
listen to it alone it's just it's kind
of like that so I I normally I'm like
I'm like please watch one episode if you
like it when we watch it again I'm so
done forcing people to watch this a 30
second beam suddenly becomes three hours
just like okay
they ask how long is this again
yeah so you you know you started off
doing anime content when did you decide
uh I want to do some other stuff as well
or was that like always kind of like
something you wanted to do so within the
first year I was I made like a video
about
um Silent Hill 2 which was a big break I
think if you go back and watch that
video I'm nearly like apologizing in it
where I'm like guys I'm so I just swear
to [__] God I'm gonna talk about Maps
like a 100 you know
um and I liked it and it was fun like I
remember views wise the video did bad
but I was kind of like it's kind of fun
though you know yeah and then um then
the big one for me is I made a video
about pro wrestling and specifically I
think it was called I think it was
originally called professional wrestling
is fascinating and I changed the name or
something I think it's called Uh pro
wrestling is dumb and beautiful and I
love it or something and um that was
like my favorite video I'd ever made I
was like this is so much fun and like I
got to tell this big story of Kenny
Omega and the golden lovers and all this
kind of stuff and that was the moment I
was like oh I think I just gotta just
gotta do what I want here you know and
yeah because I remember uh when I think
it was maybe like the first or maybe
maybe even the second time I met with
your IRL and we were in Dublin with uh
Aki and I remember we were at dinner and
you were like so Joe I need your opinion
on something I'm making this video about
The Simpsons and I'm really scared to
upload it because I feel like my
audience is gonna hate it and you like
gave me kind of the breakdown of it and
I was like no reckon you should go for
it and then you did upload it and now
it's like your most viewed video oh it
that is my most viewed video still and
until the Garfield video surpasses it
which is going to be any day now which
is deeply [__] horrifying yeah stupid
cat takes everything from me
no I mean I think like eight million
views
what God that's crazy that's insane no I
think because like I think one of the
reasons I [__] love your content you
know as a fan and also as resume is just
like your ability to sell me on any
single [__] Topic at all and get me
invested in it absolutely I'll be real
with you I I never had any interest in
wrestling and after your video I still
have not much interest in wrestling but
it was like you got me invested in
wrestling when I should never got an
invest in wrestling in the first place
it is from my own experience as well for
making a wrestling video it is really
hard to sell wrestling to people who do
not have an interesting I I don't know
why I I just I there was something that
my audience I've never seen the response
to it it wasn't negative but it was just
very unusual I've never had anything
like that if you turn on wrestling if
you turn on the average wrestling show
you're gonna see two sweaty guys in a
ring and the actual storytelling is not
appearance like the actual cool things
about it and then like the deeper you
get into it and all the great like um I
would say getting Michelle into
wrestling was a long-term project with
me for a long time and about two years
ago she said something that I was just
like I did it she just goes um there's
this wrestler called Brian Nielsen but
when he went to the WWE Vince McMahon
changed his name to Daniel Bryan and
Michelle just goes
what is wrong with minstick man and I
was like I got her I got her
bring back the old name